what's going on guys so Sylvester
Stallone and his gang of fogies are back
to blow stuff up this summer with
Expendables 3 is it going to be the
Expendables that we really want here to
talk to us with some big opinions about
the Expendables Nick Mundy look there is
no reason that the expendable cancer I'm
out shooter behind me the best time
movie franchise of all Don alright we're
gonna get to that but first I want to
say Father's Day is this weekend it's
bring your dad to work week and in the
spirit of that we have one of the most
special guests we've ever had on the
show
mr. Dennis Mundy sir it is a pleasure
nice to meet you hello good to meet you
Nick don't embarrass me are you here to
fix the Expendables are you gonna fix
Nick I have a better chance to fix in
the Expendables was he always like this
sadly yes alright let's get down to
business I want to fix the Expendables
look these movies should be great we
were kids did you not imagine putting
all of these actors together and
thinking this is going to be the
greatest movie of all time
that dream was ripped from our hearts
Nick why are we doing this this would
take 30 seconds shorten the show Nick
the movie sucked the second movie suck
Nick that's it that's the end we don't
have to do this for 5 or 10 minutes
alright well thank you for watching
screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye
though rewind that no no I'm going I got
okay I'm okay I work hard I'm gonna date
so Nick I know you have some points
let's start with number one all right
keep Sylvester Stallone out of the
creative process I think it's just
wearing too many hats he's wearing the
writers had he's worth directors hat and
he's wearing the actors had and he
should just focus on acting he's a great
actor no LOB repeat that last thing you
said you just said special it's a great
actor yeah you said good you said
Sylvester Stallone is a great act yes
yes well just a moment Dennis do you
think Sylvester Stallone is a great
actor simply no but the thing is this
could all be fixed this could all be
fixed okay they need to bring in a new
writer a new director who can you know
salvage this franchise
did you really see these movies yeah he
sucked
I know I know buddy sucked writing in
these movies there's no good quality
know that I agree with you I agree with
you dad but sounds like your dad thinks
they should just put the Expendables
franchise out of it's me
no because I believe it could still be
saved
okay you bring in a new writer like
Shane black how great would lethal one
be ashame black to write the movies you
get John McTiernan out of jail from die
hard so your solution is change the
writer yes change the actors no change
everything and you still have the
Expendables
okay what's your second point now cut
out the wig wig crap back in the glory
days of when the expendable stars were
in the 80s and they're 80 yeah they were
like these self-delusional egomaniacs
and they took everything seriously they
take they took their part seriously they
took the movies deadly seriously I may
hear of a new world disease I'm gonna
cure their God complexes like overcame
their crappy acting uh-huh and then like
gave us some great performances because
they believed in themselves so much that
this gravitas okay what's happening now
someone told The Expendables like hey
guys everyone's making fun of you and
they may think that all your light
one-liners are cheesy little some steam
in Venice they started like oh we want
to be a part of the joke not made made
the joke so we're gonna like jump in and
start doing everything wink wink II and
expendable
I'll be back you've been back enough
I'll be back
upk hey guys I'll guess I'll be back I'm
very impressed with like the
psychoanalysis you've done oh I know you
go maniac a god calm my dad has been in
town for three days and I've been
working on this the expendables have
become the scary movie of action movies
and there are parody of themselves and I
don't want that it's like a sad man
you know you know just wearing a Tommy
Bahama shirt and khaki shorts and show
it off on his son show just to get
attention well I don't know what that
but I know a strong proud man showing up
on the screen junkies show Thank You
hell yeah how shows me respect something
you've never done way to put him in this
place okay you're like the Nick Mundy
whisperer
I want to talk to you after the show sir
okay Nick do you have a third point for
us
no more lazy cameos and Expendables 3
they got Harrison Ford so this is my
prediction for Harrison Ford isn't the
reason you need to shut the movie down
before you even write a 3 I mean what
the hell is Harrison Ford gonna do in
the movie like no I'll tell you whatever
supports you to do in this movie he's
gonna show up in the helicopter say I
got a bad feeling about this
and then just take off all right let
this out therefore for both you guys a
little a little Mundy family wager
what's the your over-under on Harrison
Ford screen time sir less than a minute
let's spin a minute Wow
I think he's there for five minutes but
he's making eye contact for only 10
seconds all right Nick what's next get a
real bad guy Mel Gibson's the bad guy in
Expendables 3 and and sure he might be a
real bad guy in real life but in the
movie universe he's a good guy Nick and
totally get on board with this because
we have the iconic heroes that we loved
and we want to see an iconic villain I
don't hate it how great would it be if
they got the South African diplomat from
lethal weapon to as the bad guy in the
Expendables
I barely recollect to Oh Victor male in
the gay art dealer from Beverly Hills
Cop not that there's anything wrong with
the help but there is something wrong
with smuggling cocaine know who would be
the best bet yet hmm
Alan Rickman diehards Hans Gruber how
great would it be big thumbs up for this
yeah
the only other person I could think of
is you get the Expendables dad's there
they would have to live up to
expectations and then never could okay
we're in a whole nother you think you
can give me under dr. Phil all right
what else you got for us no more plastic
surgery Sylvester Stallone looks like a
creepy marionette his beard looks like
it was surgically attached to his face
they all have like these weird beard
implants Dennis what do you think about
men getting plastic surgery I would
never get plastic surgery I agree with
the Bruce Willis philosophy just age if
it's gracefully great if it's not so big
and if I may bring out a fun fact about
you mr. Mundy Bruce Willis was a New
York cop and die hard weren't you a
police officer I was a real cop outside
Washington DC well thank you for your
sir which took place in die hard - no
more digital squibs not everyone might
know what squibs are there because they
don't use them that much anymore if
their actual little packets of blood
that pop open out of your shirt you get
shot anything before computers had real
squibs because that was the only way you
can get blood out and what the
Expendables does which is so terrible
they not only have digital squibs
they have digital muzzle flashes which
looks worse than the digital squids I
mean it's safer what didn't we care
about safety in the 80s when there's
this passion come from Nick I've never
seen this in you before if you would
applied yourself in college look you
could have been a whole lot better than
you are now Nick and it's probably true
and you're an astro fan Nick okay
don't Nick we want that day what's your
next the issue with the Expendables
Kelsey Grammer
what about Hulk Hogan Danny Glover Carl
Weathers Reginald veljohnson
reg Nolan Ryan Nolan Ryan Lewis ball
play yeah Louis Gossett jr. Kurt Russell
Michael Douglas Rutger Hauer Peter
Weller Billy Joel that one's for my dad
you're welcome me and how could be
Expendables only because if Kelsey
Grammer could be in there
don't anyone tonight Kelsey Grammer was
beast and the worst x-men Nick we'll see
if any of your suggestions wind up in
the Expendables mr. Mundy we'll see if
any of your sage advice winds up in
Nick's life good luck good luck good
night exactly yeah my pleasure
oh are you having you sir thank you who
do you think should be in the
Expendables what's your dream cast for
an Expendables movie leave us an answer
in the comments section below best
answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt and don't forget to
click the link below for a chance to win
a car for your dad awesome this episode
is brought to you by dial for men power
scrub I want to thank Nick Mundy and I
want to thank mr. Dennis Mundy
thank you for oh thank you sir for
gracing us with your presence happy
Father's Day happy Father's Day to you
and you and you and everybody I'm Hal
Rudnick thanks for watching hit me up on
Twitter bye bye say bye bye bye